sort of
when i so you you're saying those
functions so so real numbers don't exist
real numbers
yes for something to exist it has to uh
be implemented
if it's something is not implemented
anywhere it doesn't make sense to claim
that it exists i think it's a confusion
of the notion of existence to say that
something that is not implemented and is
not implementable could exist
the things that produce patterns that we
observe in order to exist and need to be
implemented right
so uh you could say does the financial
system exist well it exists to the
degree that it's implemented there are
some boundaries very projected and it's
not actually implemented where it
doesn't actually exist only in some
course approximation but by and large
something exists right some causal
structure is implemented here the set of
all the functions between the integers
is not implementable therefore it
doesn't exist
it's something that you can specify and
this difference between specification
and existence is something that is very
obvious to a computer scientist
and sometimes not obvious to a
traditional mathematician
there is stuff that you can specify that
makes no sense it is only specifiable in
your language but that's because your
language is much more permissible than
the set of things that can be uh can
exist and computation is less
permissible computation only permits you
to build things that can actually exist
if you can build things that cannot
exist it's a problem of your language in
which you're building things it's not a
problem of reality just confused